hi there and welcome back to the future
of documents
I'm Holt Skinner and I'm a developer
advocate for Google Cloud previously
we've looked at lots of ways to process
documents including General forms IDs
receipts and even completely custom
formats using document AI however no
machine learning model is perfect and
when you need the highest accuracy for
your applications it can be best to have
people verify the results before you use
them this is where human in the loop or
hitl comes in for document AI hitl
allows you to send documents to a
dedicated human review team you can use
Google Partners or your own Workforce to
manage this
you can send unprocessed documents to
Specialists who can label or de-identify
your documents or you can send already
processed documents to verify the
results and make Corrections if needed
[Music]
before we get started let's think about
why this would be needed in the first
place
on a broad scale human in the loop is
needed everywhere that AI is applied in
production
every machine learning model is created
through the use of data for supervised
learning like what is used by document
AI this means that we need label data
that tells the model what to look for
human review can be used to label
example data the way they'd want the
modeled output additionally humans can
be used for production review after the
model has been trained and starts to
make predictions humans can be used as
an escalation path a review step to
verify that the results are accurate
for example a self-driving car might
require a human driver to take over when
road conditions are poor or an automated
contact center sends calls to a human
agent when the caller has a unique
request
and in the case of document processing
this means we have humans verify that
the processors are extracting the right
information from input documents and
manually adjusting the results if
they're not correct
so how does human review fit into a full
workflow human reviewers can be
configured in multiple ways you can have
your own in-house or partner resources
use Google hitl tools for labeling and
review or you can have a Google managed
Workforce handle it for you next you can
set up human review to be triggered
manually or automatically by using the
confidence score the confidence value is
output by document AI to indicate how
accurate the model thinks the result is
this is a number between 0 and 1 with 1
being the highest confidence that the
results are accurate keep in mind this
is different from accuracy the model
could output a low confidence score for
a correct result or a high confidence
score for an incorrect result you can
set a confidence threshold to determine
which process documents should be sent
to human reviewers this can be set on
the full document or individual entities
any output with the confidence score
below the threshold we sent for human
review so the higher the threshold the
more documents will be reviewed
you can decide this value based on how
critical accuracy is for your
application for more information be sure
to check out the best practices
documentation Linked In the description
when you configure human review on a
processor you will set a Google Cloud
Storage bucket for the output files
after the document is reviewed the
verified or corrected data will be saved
as a Json file in the document object
format
any human review operations we noted in
the revisions field of the document
object structure let's look at an
example of a document being processed
through human in the loop for production
review
suppose we have an expense parser
configured with human review and this
expense report is processed the document
image is really blurry and difficult to
read and this was the output of the
expense parser the results weren't very
accurate for some fields and the model
gave low confidence scores of 0.1
a reviewer can open up this document in
the labeling console then verify or
correct the output as needed the red
colors indicate that the field was below
the set confidence thresholds
and after completing the review here is
the updated output the mentioned text
has been corrected and the confidence
has been changed to one
much better you can also see in the
revision history that human review was
completed due to low confidence scores
let's take a look at how human review
fits into the full scope of document AI
this diagram shows all of the key
components of the platform these include
Document Preparation classification
entity extraction entity relationships
uptraining and repository human review
Works across many of these areas
including docket preparation
classification and entity extraction
also the label documents can be fed into
uptraining as ground truth examples to
help the processing models become even
more accurate over time in this diagram
the steps in blue illustrate where human
the loop can be used in this video we
discussed human in the loop and how it
plays a critical role in machine
learning workflows we also talked about
how it can be used with document AI
through production review of process
documents based on confidence or
labeling documents for training in
document AI workbench
now you can try out human Loop for
document AI check out the guide Linked
In the description for step-by-step
instructions on how to review documents
using the console
you can also find links to the
documentation which has the most
up-to-date information including
supported processors thank you so much
for watching and don't forget to like
comment and subscribe
[Music]